matthieu delormeau c'est parti les gens
te regardes tu peux te lever on y va je
vais donc comment t'es-tu commente
gilles verdez tu seras donc à côté de
mathieu chez vous mettez vous remplace
ainsi vous plaît mettez vous en place on
y va est-ce que vous pouvez vous mettre
un peu voilà alors merci je m à chaque
fois c'est une minutes d'exercice et
donc il faudra faire c'est un exercice
de 5 minutes qu'il faudra faire 4 x 4
one minute les murs ou quatre fois aimé
lui la france est allée attention ces
parts et musique
suivez bien de l'ordre allez on y va de
sa rappels de factures battu mais le
dossard
c'est pas mal allez on y va c'est bien
minutes à l'aller si je prends le match
entre le rêve et je chronométrage et des
bas
c'est parti ces minutes à des jeunes qui
ne vous a pas fait mieux québec chez
vous faites légalement vous ferez ça
donc cinq fois mais ça 4 x 3 mois la ja
programme de cinq minutes
on va faire quatre fois sa famille et
des sports à la notion dix neuf huit
sept six cinq quatre trois deux un
allez on passe à l'autre exercice une
minute on prend la balle et vous avez
tous un balai vous avez tous à balai
chez vous attention c'est bon alors je
dis d'armes année mais web
alors attention c'est parti
vous regardez bien devant vous bâle est
tendue vous descend du ve descendez vous
descendu vous descendez et vous votez et
vous changez de jambe le dos toujours
bien droit attention une minute allez
c'est parti produits et audio allez on y
va c'est bien gilles tu fais n'importe
quoi
je fais n'importe quoi et n'importe quoi
je prends le ballet fait le s'emballer
allez allez faites pas le prendre mal
allez on y va pour une minute les chéris
[Musique]
satire la juge
ouais allez on y va
ça c'est notre deuxième exercice un tube
faire et puces à des fins qu on commence
à contrôler allez on y va
allez vous reste quelques secondes
encore vous faites ça chez vous les
chéris c'est magnifique
qu'ils sont beaux gosses un ces deux là
[Musique]
là là merci c'est bon d'accord on a bien
envie de toucher les fesses au passo
troisième exercice les chefs ouais tu
poses de buy in alors attention
troisième exercice donc y aura cinq
exercices à faire quatre fois par jour
attention regardez vous mettez comme ça
alors on vous voit pas alors vous voient
prélever à ma mère
on les voit pas là on est mort voila
voila on n'en voudra c'est bon
maintenant dès jeudi à bruxelles c'est
bon pour avoir ça allez on vous voit là
alors il va râler à oued tu lèves tu
crois coup dur tu des sorts voilà c'est
la pompe poser est ce qu'on appelle la
proposer allez tout le monde tout en
maintenant
ouais
quelques jours de partout vas-y allez
vas-y magie des mots j'ai une tête dure
de partout c'est le troisième exercice à
faire pour vous chez vous c ou face à
une minute à l'est gagnent tous mangent
ils gagnent tous pensent à fatou guèye
tous nos efforts voilà allez mer c'est
aller allons y va alors on y va pour une
minute les mecs allez c'est parti
alors il va à 1 2 je pose je crois qu'à
aller c'est parfait ça chez vous vous
faites ça c'est le troisième exercice à
faire les chéris donc
ces cinq exercices d'une minute à faire
un capteur catégorie de 80 il y en aura
dernier dans un instant
et vous faites ça sans courant si c'est
trop dur vous laisse un petit on allait
au liban passe au dernier exercice
allez c'est parti
dernier exercice vous mettez pas trop
près vous mettez pas trop prix nobel il
met toi la banda la lettone mettons plus
à vannes oc ou un peu là il posé vous
regardez un mètre entre vous la jirs et
mathieu d'or merci poussez-vous là les
bras au niveau de la tête vous lever les
jambes tu lèves les jambes j allez allez
on y va
allez c'est parti il vous reste et voix
c'est comme un sac en même temps une
minute alors ouest comme cinq minutes
allez on se trouve alors il va aller du
top 100 allériot minutes comme ce serait
dur et or est de le toucher
on doit trois touchés de leur banc non
non non non non on ne sait pas du pas de
bêtises allez on y va
une minute vous êtes bien là les gars
dur le cas moi je suis content de voir
comme ça ça me fait plaisir
franchement vous êtes beau gosse gilles
fait n'importe quoi
[Musique]
allez les mecs c'est beau vous allongez
vous enlevez vos t-shirts moment si vous
avez pris ma dit mathieu va
aulas oui mais toi là mais tu es fou
loin l'un de l'autre luan à delaune
voilà à warhol lalalalalala à wade fils
tu vois tu peux devenir comme ça ah il
est beau à l'abbé jean d'or ça fait même
des dogmes et un peu plus de 100 à
l'heure
[Musique]
moustoir
booba
[Musique]
à
ouais
au supplice
quant à la merci mathieu
on fait ça 4 x 4 x enius
voilà les gars restent à distance à
silwan voiture chercher mon on est en
train de tourner avec un gilles verdez
dans l'a perdu pas du tout savage il
très bien j'ai combien de doigts 5 merci
c'est bon il est bien et bravo à mathieu
d'euros d'un prof de sport reçoit bras